so seit dieser woche endlich mal eine
gute nachricht hat deutschland wieder
eine bewegung hashtag aufstehen
gegründet von sahra wagenknecht und
ihrem mann bewegung ist so wichtig
wirklich absolut ist voll der trend es
ist der trend heutzutage will keiner
mehr partei seien alle wollen nur noch
bewegung seien klar für die gute alte
linkspartei ist das jetzt blöd gelaufen
dass die sarah jetzt ihren eigenen laden
aufmacht das war aber abzusehen denn die
stimmung zwischen ihr und der linken
parteispitze
ja ist ja schon länger so mittel
vielleicht auch sie ganz herzlich
begrüßen erwähnte das ist die
pressekonferenz der fraktion also ich
begrüße sie auch ganz herzlich
seitdem hat nie wieder jemand etwas von
patrick singer gehört er ist jetzt an
einem besseren ort
sahra wagenknecht möchte dass sich alle
eher links stehenden menschen hinter ihr
und oskar lafontaine versammeln denn das
ganze ist also eine art ja
sammlungsbewegung muss man sagen dass
ich meine
er hier ist zu einer vergangenheit eher
ein spalter aufgedreht aber warum nicht
mal sammeln leider wollen noch nicht so
viele prominente politiker mit machen
immerhin ludger vollmer ist dabei war
mal grüner parteichef die älteren
erinnern sich ungern und hier simone
lange bürgermeisterin von flensburg
simon ist ein echter co also eigentlich
hat man sich ja um kevin kühnert bemüht
aber kevin kühnert hat gesagt nee ich
bin in der spd und das ist mir auch
wichtig und simone lange war quasi die
beste die man kriegen konnte
cool wiener disco morgens um fünf
kevin kühnert wiederum hatte eigentlich
nur den newsletter von hashtag aufsteht
abonniert und wird jetzt als
gründungsmitglied geführt solche tricks
kennt man sonst nur von handyverträgen
was hashtag aufstehen noch fehlt müssen
wir sagen sind konkrete ideen ist alles
noch sehr sehr allgemein also
gerechtigkeit man müsste mal so was was
fehlt sonst noch brauchen dringend
spenden gar kein geld haben ja klar weil
wenn ihr geld hättet werde ja keine
linken aber im ernst vielleicht ist so
eine bewegung auch die richtige antwort
auf die krise unserer demokratie kann ja
sein und vielleicht braucht man hashtag
aufstehen um zb die spd daran zu
erinnern dass sie auch meine linke
partei war für die sozen gilt ja mehr so
hashtag aufgeben
ja ich so nur noch traurig auch was die
letzten wochen wieder bei der täuscht
die spd tage lang eine große
rentenreform an und dann bleibst du den
schwanz ein unterschreibt stumpf nochmal
den koalitionsvertrag
die koalition damit die schwierige
stimmung der letzten wochen jetzt
endgültig überwunden
wie wirkt es sie ja
stehen wir wieder wie auf der zugspitze
ich kann man wirklich nicht mehr helfen
tut mir leid
deutschland hat seine erste bewegung und
was für ein zufall meine damen und
herren genau in dieser woche erscheint
auch dietmar wischmeyer es neues buch
oskar und sarah 50 shades of links ja
der erste liebesroman nur für die
arbeiterklasse in einer weltpremiere
liest der autor nun exklusiv für uns aus
dem kapitel liebe kennt keine
pflegestufe
die untergehende sonne ergießt sich wie
ein brennendes meerschweinchen über den
geistigen horizont des saarlandes in
ihrem bescheidenen 40 zimmer palais tod
wird das traumpaar der deutschen linken
wie zwei frisch verliebte nebelkrähen
oscar und sarah haben soeben den eigenen
hashtag aufstehen auf ihrem partner
smartphone angeklickt sie doch nur
väterchen kluft sarah den kreisen gattin
in die seite drei klicks in den letzten
beiden stunden warten uhr bald ist das
dutzend voll und aus der idee ist eine
bewegung geworden
ludger volmer macht mit und noch zwei
von denen ich noch nie gehört habe ist
dass sich der totale wahnsinn während
sarah ob ihres erfolges wie ein gelobtes
kaltblut füllen durch den salon
gelockert kichert väterchen la fontaine
allwissend in sein spucke tuch soll das
ost mädel doch nur glauben eine
sammlungsbewegung zu gründen eher oscar
1 durch genossen beschuss gestellter
kempe wusste es besser
der plan sein plan war so einfach wie
genial
nach der spd würde auch die linke
vernichten und damit sein lebenswerk
vollenden keine außer ihm hat es
geschafft gleich zwei parteien zu
zerstören gut merkel hatte die cdu auf
dem gewissen söder würde die csu in den
abgrund stürzen aber nur er
oskar das ekel hatte den doppel sieg
eingetütet und geholfen hat ihm dabei
das flinten weiters der kommunisten
steppe über einem seit langem sexuell
hörig und nur zu bereit für väter in
ihrer partei zu opfern
schau doch nur durch goethe es aus dem
vestibül kim jong hoon athen geld aus
hannover geheiratet und heißt jetzt
rudert beim namen des alten erz-rivalen
kroll grüner schleim aus den mundwinkeln
des linken vordenkers und mit ungeahnter
kraft fetzte illegaler vom schoß der zur
salzsäule erstarrt gattin erwähne diese
namen nie wieder in meiner gegenwart
der weitere abend dem lebens nest an der
saar verlief darauf äußerst frostig doch
gegen 11 uhr schneit überraschend
alexander gauland herein mit zwei
flaschen jägermeister und am rechten arm
so wurde es doch noch ein lustiger abend
und schlussendlich hat man sich den
hashtag auf den gemeinsam schön besoffen
guten abend
[Musik]
[Applaus]